good afternoon everybody that was quick
I'm Jared Cohen the president of
Carnegie Mellon it's my great pleasure
to welcome you here to this Buell
lecture you know when we have
long-serving administrators especially
successful days I think we sort of
forget that they they had a they had a
life before they became an administrator
present company excluded of course
and I've talked about Fred Gillman your
Dean our Dean who is a distinguished
physicist and he had a long career as
such before he came to us as an
administrator and I want to take the
opportunity to introduce him rather than
him just getting up here and introducing
our speaker Fred received his PhD at
Princeton and after a postdoc yet
Caltech he joined the Stanford faculty
and slack where he was for 20 years
having established himself as a leader
in his area of physics Fred left
Stanford to head up the physics research
division at the superconducting
supercollider and if there was a silver
lining to the cancellation of the SSC
for Carnegie Mellon it was certainly the
fact that Fred came to join us after the
demise of the SSC in 1995 in those 16
years he's provided outstanding
leadership to this University as head of
the physics department and now is Dean
of the Mellon College of Science he's as
many things at his background which are
distinctive but the one I'll just
mention is his time as chair of he Papp
a high-energy physics advisory panel
from 1999 to 2006 during which he
provided national leadership
to go along with the local leadership he
was providing us who better to introduce
to you the pew lecture then the Buell
professor of theoretical physics Fred
Buehler
[Applause]
thanks Jerry for the introduction as
fuel professor of theoretical physics
I'm very pleased to welcome you to the
2011 Bo lecture this is the 16th lecture
since the series was reinstituted in
1996 thrilled to have been able to bring
Scott Aaronson to Carnegie Mellon today
to give this year's Bo lecture Scott
received his PhD in computer science at
UC Berkeley did postdocs that the
Institute for Advanced Study in the
University of Waterloo before he went to
MIT raised associate professor of
Electrical Engineering and computer
science it works on some of the deepest
problems in mathematics particularly in
the theory of computational complexity
as in what are the fundamental limits on
what can be efficiently computed he's
the creator and zookeeper of the online
complexity Zoo website I confess to
still be in the petting zoo wandering
around a little mystified and also he
writes a very popular blog
www.guaranteedprofit.com Aronson will
take us on a tour of the mathematical
world of complexity speaking on quantum
computing and the limits of the
efficiently computable
[Applause]
okay well thank you so much to a Fred
and to everyone else it's always a
pleasure to be here at Carnegie Mellon
so you know to to be honest when I was
invited here I didn't understand the the
the the scope I said sure I'll be happy
to you know talk to I thought for a few
physicists I didn't realize I'd be in
this jungle here or something you know
you know feels like maybe maybe this
this is like a royal wedding okay but so
I wanted to tell you something about
quantum computing and the limits of the
efficiently computable this here is an
actual photo of a quantum computer well
I did it I did a Google image search for
quantum computer and this is what came
up so well all right so the starting
point for this talk is that there are
certain technologies that would be
really great if we had them I would
certainly love them and yet we we never
seem to see them okay and you can ask
why not the first one of these is warp
drive okay you know you know we've been
watching it you know in science fiction
where is it
okay we're waiting so the second is the
perpetual motion machine okay this is
clearly the only long-term solution to
the world's energy problems okay again
you know why we can describe it why
don't we say it okay and now the third
maybe a little bit less common but I
think just as interesting it's what I'll
call the uber computer okay so this is a
computer that sort of instantly answers
any well posed mathematical question
that you can put to it all right I'm not
even going to talk about asking it the
meaning of life or something like that
okay I'm just asking that it should
instantly answer you know any any
mathematical question okay and you know
despite whether it may sometimes seem
like we don't have that
you know even the fastest computers on
earth if you ask them some problem about
a finding the proof of some hard theorem
they may not be able to do it within the
entire lifetime of the universe okay and
in fact this is why there are still
human mathematicians today okay so okay
so so now you know when we when we when
we look at these three devices we can
ask why do they seem to be impossible
what why do we not have them is that is
it just limitations of engineering that
you know no one has put cranks and
levers together and the right way to
build them well at least in the first
two cases we have a pretty good idea
that the answer is no that in fact the
impossibility of these devices is linked
to some of the deepest principles in
physics okay so in the first case we
don't have faster than light travel or
communication because special relativity
tells us that the structure of
space-time just doesn't permit that if
you were to go faster than light you're
also going backwards in time okay in the
second case we don't have perpetual
motion machines because they would
violate the second law of thermodynamics
okay so what about the third case you
know is the third case just sort of a
technological accident or is there also
some Funt fundamental physical reasons
why we don't see Boober computers okay
so in this talk I'm going to try to
convince you that sort of the limits of
computation are also like these other
two examples telling us something
important about the physical world okay
and that therefore they're something
that not just computer scientists but
also physicists should be worried about
and in fact that maybe we can even turn
it around and use it to to say something
new about physics okay all right so this
talk is going to require like a five
minute crash course in some of the
fundamental concepts of my own field of
computational complexity theory okay so
I'll go quickly through this okay but
basically in in theoretical computer
science and the field of complexity
theory were interested in problems
and how fast you can solve them or what
kind of resources you need to solve them
okay now what do we mean by a problem
well you know the standard example would
be I sort of just some infinite sequence
of yes-or-no questions okay so for
example I would give you a flight map
and I would ask you is every airport
reachable from every other one in five
flights or less okay so you know a
simple question now an important point
any particular map is just an instance
of the of the general problem okay the
set of all possible maps now that's a
problem okay computer scientists are a
little bit you know snobbish about this
okay you know give me an infinite family
of things okay that's a problem okay and
and so you know what you'd like is some
general method or algorithm or procedure
that solves any given instance of the
problem of course for this or that
particular instance you may find some
clever way maybe you can even do it on
pencil and paper but you know you want a
general procedure that you could feed
your computer that always works
okay now the size of an instance usually
just means the number of bits needed to
write it down okay or you can think
interchangeably like in this example the
size of the instance is going to be
roughly the number of cities okay
and now we we would like algorithms that
solve these problems and usually you
know there's some trivial way to solve
it which is that you could just
enumerate all of the possibilities okay
but we don't want that we want some way
to solve the problem efficiently okay
now so what do we mean by efficient so
we have this notion called polynomial
time an algorithm is polynomial time if
it uses a number of steps that grows
basically like the size of the instance
to some fixed power okay so it could
grow like N or like N squared that's
also okay
it could even grow like n to the hundred
which doesn't sound very efficient but
you know it doesn't tend to come up very
often in practice okay what it shouldn't
do is grow like 2 to the N okay that's
exponential growth and
that that's what we don't want okay so
now you know there are Fred mentioned
this complexities ooh it has about 500
different classes of problems solvable
with different resources but maybe the
most fundamental one that started it all
it's called P okay it's polynomial time
missus simply the class of all problems
for which there there is a deterministic
polynomial time algorithm on a
conventional computer that solves every
instance okay so you can think of it
roughly as the class of all feasible
problems okay so now the second class of
you should mention is called NP
non-deterministic polynomial time
okay now you know I have to tell you I
envy the physicist because you know a
lot of even if people don't understand
what they're talking about either at
least they have awesome names for things
like quark supersymmetry black hole you
know computer scientists were stuck with
P and NP okay but it really is just as
interesting okay so so what is this NP
okay so n pays basically just the class
of all problems for which you can
efficiently recognize an answer if it's
given to you okay so if the answer is
yes there should be a short proof that
it's yes which can be checked in
polynomial time okay so it might be very
hard to solve the problem but at least
you can recognize the answer a classic
example of an NP problem would be
factoring a giant integer like that one
here okay so I could ask you some
yes-or-no question like does this number
have a prime or have any factor let's
say ending in 7 okay and now you know if
you if I gave you this problem and asked
you to solve it it might take an
astronomical amount of time you could
say well does 3 go into it no this 5 go
in no there's you know you'll be doing
that for a while okay but on the other
hand if I gave you the factors then you
know you could multiply them together
and say oh I guess I guess it did have a
factor ending in 7 okay that that
wouldn't be as hard of a computation
certainly not for a computer you know it
can multiply numbers pretty quickly okay
so all right so so
now there's this concept of an np-hard
problem a problem is called np-hard
basically if it captures the difficulty
of every NP problem so basically these
are the problems that if you had a way
to solve them then you could use that to
solve all of the NP problems okay
now the final concept is a problem is
called np-complete if it's both np-hard
and it's in NP okay so basically the
np-complete problems are the hardest
problems for which it's easy to check
the solution okay so you know you have
to think about that for a bit but but
you know you know you know this sounds
like just playing around with words but
the profound discovery that people made
in the 1970s that really started this
whole field of complexity theory you
know in the in its sort of modern
incarnation was that a huge number of
practical problems that people care
about you know actually all belong to
this np-complete class okay so you know
problems from physics from economics
from biology from you know all kinds of
fields you know now one one famous
example is what's called the Hamilton
cycle problem okay so here I would show
you a map like this with a bunch of
cities the yellow dots and some are
connected to each other and I would ask
you this is there a way to is there a
tour that visits each city exactly once
okay now in this case there is one
what's that okay and if I show it to you
then it's not hard to check it and say
yes indeed it you know it solves the
problem okay but if I don't show you the
tour then you know you may have to think
about it and and as the number of cities
increases the difficulty of the problem
may you know increase a lot okay it's
like or think of solving a jigsaw puzzle
that's another example of an np-complete
problem okay or Sudoku is another okay
and also you know many other problems of
more economic
importance okay you know airline
scheduling things like things like that
okay
so it's to give you the brief layout of
the world so at the very bottom we have
paid sir you know I think of all of the
problems for which you know we know a
feasible way to solve them with today's
computers okay so you know and there's
lots and lots of non-obvious things in
here like testing whether a number is
prime or composite
you know linear programming lots of
interesting stuff okay but then above it
you know there's this whole class of
problems you know and be complete ones
for which no one knows of any efficient
way to solve them you know and most of
us believe that there isn't one okay
this is also a huge class containing
lots and lots of practical problems you
know and then certainly there's plenty
of stuff that's even harder than NP
complete okay one famous example is the
halting problem I give you a program you
want to know whether it will ever stop
running or not okay and then very
interestingly there are these problems
that that we think lie in an
intermediate region between P and NP
complete ok so there are NP problems
that are floating in the middle
somewhere and a famous example of that
is one I already showed you this problem
of factoring large numbers okay and as
we're going to see these problems that
are in this intermediate region you know
there's not that many of them but
they're hugely important sort of both on
the one hand for cryptography and on the
other hand for quantum computing okay
okay so the literally million-dollar
question here and I mean you know if you
solve it you actually get a million
dollars from the clay math Institute is
whether P equals NP okay so in other
words can all of the problems for which
you can recognize the answer efficiently
if someone gives it gives it to you can
can you actually find the answer
efficiently okay can you actually solve
the problem efficiently so it's getting
you know are the classes P and NP equal
okay you're equivalently we want to know
just can the np-complete problems be
solved
polynomial-time are not okay and this is
a profound mathematical question you
know the probably the shortest proof of
its importance I can give you is that
it's appeared on both the Simpsons and
Futurama based on cameos so you know
this is a problem which has entered the
popular culture so you know now the
problem as far as anyone knows was sort
of first asked actually in 1956 in a
letter that curt girdle you know the
incompleteness guy wrote to a John von
Neumann but annoying man at the time was
dying of cancer in the hospital and
girdle wrote this letter that said my
dear von Neumann I hear that you're
getting better which he wasn't but since
you are let me take the liberty of
troubling you with a mathematical
problem and he then asked problem that
today we would immediately recognize as
the P versus NP problem okay he asked
sort of is there a general decision
procedure that given a mathematical
question will tell you whether it has a
proof of n symbols or less okay we know
from we knew from the great work of
girdle and Alan Turing in the 1930s that
there can be no general decision
procedure for mathematics tells you
whether a statement as a proof or not
this is what about just a proof of n
symbols or less okay this is clearly a
finite problem you know in principle you
could just enumerate every possible
proof one after the other and see if any
of them worked okay but you know is
there actually an efficient procedure
one that takes a number of steps that
grows like n or like N squared let's say
instead of like two to the N power okay
that grows algebraically instead of
geometrically okay and he says if such a
procedure existed it would have
consequences of the greatest magnitude
it would mean that the mental effort of
the mathematician could be completely
replaced by machine and then he pays a
little asterisk and he says apart from
the postulation of axioms okay so
basically you know here's what he's
saying so P versus NP is
recognized as one of the greatest
unsolved problems in mathematics right
you know it's one of these seven clay
problems alongside the Riemann
hypothesis the punker a conjecture which
was solved almost a decade ago by a
Grisha Pearlman you know and several
others okay but in my opinion P versus
NP is actually manifestly the most
important of the seven problems it's the
greatest mathematical problem and the
argument for this is simply that if P
were equal to NP then probably you could
not only solve that one problem but also
the other six okay because you would
simply program your computer to find the
proofs for you okay so this is a math
problem but it's also a problem about
the nature of mathematical reasoning
itself okay so this is the P versus NP
problem why it's important okay okay but
you know people have been asking this
question for you know more than 40 years
now I should tell you that you know I
think a lot of you know there's been a
lot of progress you know there were
there there have been some breakthroughs
proving things that are you know nowhere
near P naught equal to NP but some sort
of baby results people are you know we
know more than we did than people did in
the 70s right but you know it's it's a
tremendously difficult problem now
because of this blog that I write I get
solutions to this problem in my inbox I
would say every other week or so either
that they're equal or that they're not
equal you know in in a couple cases they
were accompanied by death threats if I
didn't publish them okay but the the
most recent serious attempts some of you
may have seen was this summer a guy
named vanadium our car who had actually
what looked like a serious attempt for
the proof and them you know I was on
vacation at the time people were
flooding me with emails is this correct
or not I look you know I I could tell
that it almost certainly wasn't correct
but I I didn't know where a mistake was
so I said look you know if he gets this
million-dollar prize
so I'll supplemented by $200,000 okay
and I thought that couldn't possibly be
Hershel I was wrong about that but if
but in any case the long story short is
that I I didn't I I didn't have to give
up my house the the problem is still
it's still open is still extremely
difficult and you know we hope that that
someday mathematics will advance will
will have advanced to the point where we
can tackle questions like this one but
but in the meantime you know we can
think we can continue to think about P
versus NP as a purely mathematical
question which it is and that's great
okay but there's also a different
perspective that we can take on it okay
and that's that there's actually a very
important presupposition that sort of
underlies that P versus NP question or
you know why why do we ask the question
in this particular way and not some
other way okay and that presupposition
is called the extended church touring
thesis basically this is the thesis that
the this theoretical model of a computer
that we've been working with since the
1930s which is called the Turing machine
is really the right model for what can
be computed in a reasonable amount of
time in the in the physical universe
okay so you know there was an original
Church touring thesis which said that
the touring machine captures what if
something can be computed in any amount
of time in the physical world then it
can also be computed by a Turing machine
okay and that I say it's fair to say I
think that there's been no serious
challenge to that thesis not even
quantum computing does anything to
challenge that okay but then there's the
extended version which says that if
something can be efficiently computed
computed in polynomial time in the
physical world then it can also be
computed in polynomial time by a Turing
machine either a deterministic or maybe
a probabilistic one okay and that thesis
has always been on shaky err ground and
in fact you know you're going to see
shortly that quantum computing poses a
serious challenge to it okay so so you
know so so we could ask
you know how okay just in general how
sure are we of this thesis you know what
are the challenges to it that have been
put forward over the years all right so
let's start with sort of the challenges
that have been to these extended
church-turing thesis that computer
scientists have sort of kicked around
since the 1970s or so so my personal
favorite is that you could violate the
extended church-turing thesis and exceed
the computational capacity of a Turing
machine using a tub of soapy water okay
so how exactly would that work okay so
what you would do is you would take two
glass plates and you would put pegs
between them you know in whatever
configuration you wanted okay and then
you would you know take this thing and
dump it you know just hold it that into
a tub of soapy water and you would take
it out and what you see is some soap
bubbles which will form okay and in
general bubbles like to reach a minimum
energy configuration and this more or
less corresponds to minimizing the total
length of bubbles connecting the pegs
together okay and so in other words you
know if the bubbles really relax into
the lowest energy state then they ought
to relax into what computer scientists
and mathematicians know as the minimum
Steiner tree okay so this is the minimum
total length of line segments connecting
a bunch of points in the Euclidean plane
where those segments could meet could
also meet at intermediate points okay so
I've shown an example here now the
interesting thing is that this minimum
Steiner tree problem is known to be
np-hard okay and yet nature seems to
solve it you just you know dip these
pegs in the soapy water right and just
let nature find the lowest energy State
okay so there was a discussion of this
on the internet some years ago and you
know people made the the point that I
think was important here which is that
well systems in nature you know can can
be amazing and trying to find solutions
to optimization problems but we also
know
that they can get stuck in local minima
okay so for example if you had a rock
and some crevice and a mountainside it
could reach a lower state of potential
energy by rolling up first and then
rolling down and yet it's rarely
observed to do that okay so you know why
not why why shouldn't things be the same
with these pegs right there might be
some you know completely optimal way to
connect the pegs together but if you've
you know put put together a system of
pegs such that the minimum Steiner tree
connecting them together encodes a proof
of the Riemann hypothesis which in
principle one can do yes it NP
completeness tells you right then you
know why on earth would you expect
nature to find that optimal
configuration instead of one of the
thousands and thousands of suboptimal
ones that it could happily you know for
get to okay and then you know some other
people were arguing with this and they
said well you know this is just really
this academic computer science party
line I bet none of you are saying this
ever actually went and did the
experiment so this was my only for a in
my life into experimental physics so I
went to the hardware store did it it
looks very it's very cool with like five
or six pegs you should actually try it
it's nice but then you know you start
adding more pegs seven pegs eight pegs
and indeed you can find that sometimes
it does not reach an optimal
configuration okay sometimes you even
have cycles which which which which we
know actually can't be optimal it has to
be a tree okay so alright so so much for
this there are other approaches that
people have put forward for trying to
solve np-complete problems in in nature
one is that if you look at proteins
you know the proteins are really amazing
they somehow fold very quickly into some
low energy state and if you formalize
this problem in the right way you can
actually show that the problem of
finding the minimum energy folding
configuration for a protein is again
np-complete okay and yet again the
proteins do it okay but again the res
solution is that you know a proteins are
actually specifically evolved over you
know billions of years so that the
minimum energy configuration will be
easy to find okay so that it will be an
easy computational problem if you you
know design the protein where it's a
hard computational problem then there's
sort of no very good reason to expect it
to reach its minimum energy state okay
and in fact even in nature we do
sometimes see proteins that fold into
the quote unquote wrong configuration so
these are a prions for example the agent
of mad cow disease
okay people have also proposed using DNA
computers which would be this massively
parallel you know a way of trying to
solve these hard optimization problems
but from our perspective DNA computer is
really sort of a very very parallel
classical computer so in other words the
amount of DNA that you need to put in
your test tube will increase
exponentially with the size of the
problem that you're trying to solve
until you you know have to convert the
whole earth into DNA or something okay
so this again is not a scalable solution
all right ah but what about quantum
computing okay you knew it was coming at
some point okay so so this is you know
was an amazing new idea in a you know I
guess both in physics and in the theory
of computation that you know widespread
attention starting around 17 years ago
and what's the idea well the idea is to
exploit sort of quantum mechanics which
has been our fundamental framework for
almost all of physics for almost 90
years now the you know you hear a lot of
things about quantum mechanics that it's
about light being both a particle and a
wave that it's about you know
um hydrogen atom having these you know
discrete energy levels that it's about
randomness you know the this and that
from from a computer scientist
perspective quantum mechanics is simply
a generalization of probability theory
okay where instead of probabilities
which are non-negative real numbers we
replace them by these numbers called
amplitudes which can be complex numbers
you know and so in particular they can
have minus signs in them okay and you
know for whatever reason nature seems to
prefer things that way okay so you know
and once all of the quantum phenomena
that people talk about like entanglement
and interfere and so and they're all
sort of just sort of implicit logical
consequences of this one change that you
make to foundations of probability okay
so contrary to with reputation quantum
mechanics is actually unbelievably
simple once you take the physics out
okay so so in particular you know this
perspective you know lets us easily talk
about what is the idea behind quantum
computing so in the 1980s Richard
Fineman and David Deutsch and and
several others noticed the of something
very interesting that if you have a
quantum system with let's say n
particles then in order to describe the
state that that system is in at a given
time you seem to need not just n numbers
or 2n or 3n you know as in classical
physics but actually something like 2 to
the N power ok because you need to give
one of these amplitudes these you know
sort of minus sign probability things to
every possible configuration that all an
of the particles could be in ok and a
number of such configurations increases
exponentially with the number of
particles ok now this is a mind-boggling
fact about physical reality you mean it
it sort of it took a while for you know
this to really sink in but I think in
retrospect this is really you know you
know arguably these central or one of
these central facts about quantum
mechanics and in particular what it you
know it's it's a it's a huge practical
problem for people who try to simulate
quantum physics on classical computers
it means you have an exponential
slowdown okay what Fineman you know and
Deutsch and the others noticed is hey
maybe you could turn that around why not
build your computer out of quantum
mechanical elements and then you know
you won't have that exponential slowdown
problem okay but then what you've really
built is a fundamentally new kind of
computer one that could in principle
solve some problems exponentially faster
than any of the computers that we use
today so then you could ask what else is
it good for besides you know the just
the task of simulating quantum physics
which is sort of what just what it could
do in its sleep okay so yeah I like to
describe quantum computing as the power
of 2 to the N complex numbers working
for you
okay now as I guess is well known
actually building a scalable a quantum
computer turns out to be damn hard and
the basic reason is that once a quantum
computer state is measured then it
reverse to being classical okay you sort
of you know a quantum computer is in
what's called this superposition with
all these different amplitudes for all
the different possible states that it
could be in okay but once you measure it
you force it to make up its mind okay
and and then it's just in one state and
and you know you know you don't get to
measure twice one you know once once you
measure you get an answer out then it's
gone okay so and this applies not just
for for measurements that you would do
but for measurements that are implicitly
performed by any stray particle that may
happen to pass through your system okay
and so so what this means is that to
build a scalable quantum computer you
would have to keep it extremely well
isolated from the rest of the world but
at the same time be able to go in and
actually do the computation okay so it's
those twin requirements that are sort of
the reason why we don't have scalable
quantum computers yet okay the the
what's been done after sort of a decade
of work and sort of more than a billion
dollars spent at yeah by research groups
all over the world is that a quantum
computer has with high probability shown
that fifteen equals three times five
okay twenty-one might be next but but
you know scaling it up is extremely hard
because of this decoherence problem okay
but on the other hand no one has been
able to articulate any clear reason why
it should not be possible in principle
okay some computer scientists will tell
you that it must not be possible because
if it were possible then you could you
know quickly factor huge numbers and
solve these hard problems that's sort of
a circular argument okay but you know so
I think that we're really in the
situation maybe of you know Charles
Babbage in the 1830s right we have the
theory it ought to work but you know in
his case it took more than a century for
the transistor to be you know well
q tube or the transistor to be invented
and for the technology to catch up with
the theory in this case we have no idea
how long it's going to take fortunately
that won't concern me for this talk I'm
going to talk about what could be done
in principle you know and if with the
quantum computer and if you don't like
it I think I personally tend to think
that we will see you know either
practical quantum computers or what
would be even more interesting than that
you know a reason why building a quantum
computer is impossible you know one or
the other in any case long before we see
a test of string theory for example ok
ok so an important point so so I say a
journalist beware because this is
something that almost every popular
article about quantum computing ever
written has gotten wrong ok and you know
it it got to the point where I started a
whole section on my blog which was
called speaking truth to parallelism ok
because you know every writer seems to
want to describe a quantum computer as
this massively parallel classical
computer that could just sort of compute
all of the possible answers in parallel
and then instantly pick out the best one
okay you know and in fact just this week
there was a whole there's a whole long
article about quantum computing in the
new yorker maybe some of you have seen
it but you know it just repeats the same
mistake that some of us have been trying
to correct for 12 years so ok so you
know one one one one one one one one
mind at a time so in this case I guess
but so so a quantum computer once again
it has X in this exponential number of
states that are all you know so you have
this this exponential is exponential a
long list of amplitudes that are
describing your quantum computer state
ok which is an amazing fact and you know
and it's a and it is very different from
anything in classical physics the
problem is that as soon as you
measure the quantum computer or they
said you only get out one outcome okay
and therefore you know uh so you could
say look it's like you know I don't know
what state the machine is in and then I
look and then I do know
you know what's magic about that right
so if there's any hope of getting a
speed-up by this type of computer of
doing something which a classical
computer cannot do then everything rests
on one fact which is that amplitudes can
interfere with each other okay so you
know you of all of the different sort of
paths that could lead to a given answer
so you know some can have positive
amplitude others can have negative
amplitude if that's the case then those
amplitudes will cancel each other out
with the result being that that answer
will you know possibly not be observed
at all okay that is the thing about
quantum mechanics that makes it
different from just classical
probabilities or classical randomness
okay and all of the hope of solving
problems more quickly with a quantum
computer you know is rests on exploiting
that type of interference in some clever
ways to solve certain specific problems
faster than we know how to solve them
with today's computers okay know this
idea was was around since the 80s but no
one knew what this was it was actually
good for okay so no one knew how to
actually create this pattern of
interference that would reveal the
solution to some hard computational
problem it sounded like a very tall
order okay wasn't obvious whether
quantum computer would be good for
anything at all okay so that's why okay
the first thing to do was for sort of
computer scientists to sort of get a
hold of this and you know give it give
it a sequence of capital letters okay so
this was my advisor in mesh Raja Ronnie
and his then student ethan bernstein
define a quantum generalization of p of
polynomial time this class has called
bqp for bounded error Quantum polynomial
time okay basically this is just the
class of all of those problems which are
feasibly solvable by a quantum computer
okay again
you know using a number of quantum
operations that increases only
polynomially with the problem size okay
and you know and you say look everything
is probabilistic in quantum mechanics so
we'll only insist on say a 90% chance of
getting the right answer okay if you're
not happy with that just repeat the
computation several times and you can
boost that to a 99.9 percent confidence
or however great you want okay that
that's what the B is saying okay so once
we had bqp
we could then sort of actually think
about it like mathematicians and ask the
question of how great is its extent what
does it contain okay and here a profound
breakthrough happened in 1994 when Peter
shor who's then at Bell Labs now at MIT
showed that the problem of factoring an
integer into its prime factors which I
mentioned to you before is in bqp okay
so he found an extremely clever way to
exploit interference in order to
actually find the period of periodic
functions there's something called the
quantum Fourier transform okay and it
was known since the 70s that if you
could find the periods of periodic
functions then you could use that to
factor numbers okay now why do we care
about factoring numbers is it because
you know we're mathematicians we love
you know number theory in primes well
sure but it's also because most of the
world's cryptography today happens to
rely on the assumption that factoring
huge numbers is a hard problem okay if
you ever order something from Amazon or
Ebay or whatever the encryption that
your web browser is using to protect
your credit card number depends on this
assumption that factoring is hard okay
if sure showed that if a quantum
computer is built then that assumption
fails okay so this was one reason my
people got interested so just to
complete our our world map so so so I
told you before the factoring is one of
these problems that seems to be floating
in an intermediate region between P and
NP complete
okay so what sure showed is that bqp
which is the quantum generalization of P
actually snags factoring okay it's you
know sort of sufficiently larger than P
that it actually captures this very very
practically interesting problem of
factoring huge numbers okay now I drew
bqp is not encompassing the np-complete
problems okay this is a big open problem
to this day we don't know whether bqp
contains the np-complete problems or not
okay so remember you know if all your
factoring is neither known or believed
to be np-complete in fact we have very
strong evidence that it is not
np-complete okay now today many of us
believe that bqp does not contain the
np-complete problems in other words that
there is not a fast quantum algorithm to
solve all of these these np-complete
problems okay
not surprisingly we can't prove that it
doesn't ok mote you know there there's
there's very little that we can prove
and there's in this field there's a lot
that we can conjecture okay so I mean
look we don't even know if classical
computers can solve np-complete problems
in polynomial time right that's the P
versus NP question so if we can't even
prove that P doesn't contain NP then how
are how on earth are we going to prove
that bqp doesn't contain it okay so yeah
so it's an open problem but on the other
hand certainly no one knows how to use
quantum interference to solve
np-complete problems okay and in fact we
have some evidence that it if it's
possible at all it's going to be
extremely hard particular there is a
great result of bennett bernstein
Brassard and Vaz irani from 97 which
says that in some sense quantum magic
will not be enough to solve np-complete
problems okay so what they showed is
that if you were to throw away the
structure of an np-complete problem and
just envision it as you have this
abstract space of 2 to the N possible
solutions to some really hard problem
okay and for each solution the only
thing you know how to do is to just you
know feed it to some to some machine
that tells you is it is is this a valid
solution or is it not one okay let's say
just one solution out of all these two
to the N is a valid one so you're
looking for a needle in an exponentially
large haystack okay then what be BBV
showed is that you're going to have to
ask a lot of questions to that haystack
okay you're gonna have to spend a lot of
time sifting through the haystack now
that's obvious if you're a classical
person right if you have if you've got a
needle in a haystack of size two to the
end well I'm probably it's gonna take
exponential time you've just you know
that's a lot of hay okay but you know
what if you're a quantum computer and
you can ask questions about every
possible you know location in the
haystack in superposition and then do
some coherent quantum transformation on
that you know then could you somehow
magically you know just converge on the
needle in like one or two steps okay
what they show is that that's actually
not possible and that the best that you
can do in that kind of situation is do
you can you can find the needle using a
number of steps that scales only like
the square root of the number of pieces
of hay okay you can get a quadratic
speed-up over what a classical computer
could do so for example if there were
two to the ten thousand pieces of hairy
now you don't need two to the ten
thousand time you merely need two to the
five thousand time okay and okay so so
bbbb proved that that's the best
possible and then actually after that
olive grove ER showed that actually that
square root speed-up can be achieved
okay so this this loop gives the second
most famous quantum algorithm after
assures a factoring algorithm Grover's
search algorithm okay Grover's search
algorithm was actually proved to be
optimal before it was discovered to
exist okay so you know for this general
type of problem
the square-root speed-up is the best you
can hope for it's still impressive it's
still something amazing and cool but
it's not exponential
okay doesn't turn an exponentially hard
problem into a polynomial one okay so
what this is telling us is that if there
is some way to solve np-complete
problems efficiently using a quantum
computer then you're going to have to
somehow exploit the structure of the
problems okay just as a classical
algorithm would have to so you're now in
a regime where you know we we sort of
you know there's lots of things you
could try no one really knows what to do
okay now there's there's one quantum
algorithm that's been put forward
basically the wood that does attempt to
exploit the structure of these
np-complete problems in order to solve
them faster this is called the quantum
adiabatic algorithm okay and it was
proposed by Edie far he and Jeffery
Goldstone and several of my other
colleagues over in the physics
department at MIT 11 years ago okay and
they actually developed this algorithm
by using their intuition from from
physics and from condensed matter
systems for example and they said look
you can start out you know applying some
Hamiltonian don't worry what that is I
you know I myself only learned you know
after I'd been in the field for some
time it's some you know physical
operation okay and it has you know and
there's some state some lowest energy
state that if you apply this operation H
sub I to assist them then your system
likes to be in its lowest energy State
okay then we you can have another
Hamiltonian call it H sub F whose lowest
energy state actually encodes the
solution to an np-complete problem okay
it's not hard to design one of these
hamiltonians because you know just some
set of physical interactions between a
collection of particles that's that's
all it really means such that the lowest
energy configuration for those particles
to be and is the solution to an
np-complete problem like you know
Hamilton cycle like the satisfiability
something like that
okay now there's a theorem it's been
known since the 1920s called the
adiabatic theorem and what it says is
that if you start out applying this
Hamiltonian with some easily prepared
ground state and then if you just slowly
vary the Hamiltonian over time until it
becomes H sub F then as long as you vary
it slowly enough the ground state at
each instant of time will simply be that
the system will just be in the ground
state of whatever Hamiltonian you're
currently applying okay so you can just
sort of drag the ground state along
until by the end it will be in the
ground state of H sub F and you will
thereby solve your np-complete problem
okay so this was an amazing observation
and amazing connection between
theoretical computer science and
condensed matter physics okay but then
the key question that this left is okay
so how slowly do you need to slap the
thing right you know if the thing is
going to stay in the ground state and
not jump to some you know local optimum
to some other state okay so you know so
it turns out that the the the speed was
that you need to drag the thing depends
on actually the spectral gap of the
Hamiltonian so as you vary it you know
this this H sub I is described by some
matrix a or set called H sub T and the
running time the the the time the the
algorithm is scales like the inverse of
the gap between the smallest and the
second smallest eigen values of that
Hamiltonian okay and so people looked at
so now the KO question was how small can
this gap big okay the smaller the gap
the longer you've got to run the
algorithm for and what was eventually
discovered is that if H sub f
corresponds to certain hard instances of
np-complete problems then this gap may
need to be exponentially small okay so
you know it even it looks you look at
the graph it looks like the two lines
are crossing each other but they're not
quite there's this tiny little gap where
they almost kiss each other but not
quite okay
just because of that one little point
that you've got to run the algorithm for
exponential time if it wasn't for that
you would be solving an np-complete
problem in polynomial time okay but you
know the amazing thing about this is
that if you believe already that
np-complete problems are hard then you
could actually make a prediction about
the behavior of condensed matter
physical systems you could say that this
gap has to decrease exponentially in
fact some of us did say that we were
kind of going out on a limb because we
didn't know anything about physics okay
but we ended up being right so you know
and actually far he told me that he's
spoken to condensed matter experts and
said based on all of your experience
with these physical systems do you think
the spectral gap will decrease
polynomial e or exponentially as the
size of the system is increased and he's
a expert or I forget the name some guru
in the field said I think it will
decrease exponentially and far he said
well why do you say that and the guy
said because otherwise your algorithm
would work
okay so this is an example of how you
can sort of you know if you if you
believe that you know these problems are
probably hard then you know you could
sort of turn that around and sort of say
what are the implications for physics
just like you know if you you already
believe that you can't communicate
faster than the speed of light then that
in turn implies other things about the
laws of physics okay all right so what
else could you do if you wanted to solve
if you really really wanted to solve
these np-complete problems and you put
mathematicians out of business okay so
now I'm going to tell you about some
speculative changes to the laws of
physics that would enable np-complete
problems to be solved this is the fun
part of the talk okay
the the first example is so you look at
the Schrodinger equation which is the
governing equation of mass amount of
sorry of quantum mechanics and this you
know amazing thing about this equation
is that it's exactly linear it's a
linear differential equation okay but
people have speculated like Stephen
Weinberg and other physicists for a long
time about what would happen if you
inserted tiny nonlinear terms into the
Schrodinger equation maybe too tiny to
have been detected yet okay and it was
realized that all kinds of crazy things
would happen for example you could then
communicate information faster than
light okay and but in 98 Abrams and
Lloyd pointed out that another crazy
thing that would happen in such a
scenario is that then quantum computers
really would be able to solve
np-complete problems in polynomial time
okay and I can explain how it works with
just a picture so it's very easy to
create a quantum state assay of one
quantum bit one qubit that will be in
some particular will be pointing in some
particular direction quantum state is
just a vector okay so let's say it'll be
pointing this way if there are no
solutions to some np-complete problem
and if there's one solution that are
between almost the same way but just
sort of exponentially a small amount up
okay so now of course the you know the
problem in conventional quantum
mechanics so yeah you can make these
states but if you wanted to actually
distinguish them from each other then
you would need to repeat the experiment
an exponential number of times okay
because these states are so close that
when you make a measurement you know
almost always you're gonna get the same
answer okay you're only exponentially
unlikely to even see the difference
between these two okay so this doesn't
give you a practical way of solving
np-complete problems quantum
mechanically okay but Abrams and Lloyd
pointed out well what if the Schrodinger
equation were nonlinear okay in that
case there could be transformations on
states that would not have to preserve
the angle between pairs of states and so
what you could do is sort of have these
states and then just sort of gradually
pry them apart okay you could apply some
nonlinear transformation sort of very
generically that just sort of increases
the angle between them until they're
orthogonal or almost orthogonal in which
case they can be easily distinguished by
a measurement okay so you know now one
conclusion you could draw from this is
wow that's awesome we should go out and
look for these nonlinearities because
then we can solve np-complete problems
okay another conclusion you could draw
is maybe this is actually providing us
an additional explanation as to why the
Schrodinger equation is linear okay now
one of my personal favorites is the
relative quantum computers are not going
to do it then how about the relativity
computer
okay now the idea here is an extremely
simple one you would start your computer
working on some incredibly hard problem
doesn't even have to be an NP problem
you know some really hard calculation
then you leave your computer on earth
okay then you board a spaceship which is
traveling it very close to the speed of
light okay then you you get you come
back to earth now billions of years have
passed in earth time all of your friends
are long dead civilization has collapsed
but you've got the answer to your
np-complete problem okay so what's the
problem with this you know why why don't
people try it right so
all right well I think there's actually
something to say about this cuz you know
you can say all right that sounds kind
of silly but no seriously why doesn't it
work what goes wrong right and actually
if you think about it enough I think
that the the answer to that question has
to do with the amount of energy that you
would need in order to accelerate
sufficiently close to the speed of light
okay what you can show is that to get an
exponential speed-up you would actually
have to accelerate you know so much that
the the there would be only an
exponentially small difference between
your speed and that of light okay to do
that requires an exponential amount of
energy which then implies that your fuel
tank or whatever is powering your
spaceship it probably ought to be
exponentially large okay so then you're
again needing to spend exponential time
you know just to build the tank right or
for the fuel from the far part of the
tank to affect you okay and so you know
again you're you know it's needing
exponential time but just for a
different reason okay this is a good
example of how when you look at only one
or two things about the laws of physics
it can look like you have some hyper
computing power so amazing computational
power but then when you take everything
into account it always seems to go away
okay another of my favorites is what I
call the Z no computer this is also a
very simple idea okay you would do the
first step of your computation in one
second you do the second step in half a
second you do the third step in a
quarter second the fourth step in an
eighth second and so on so that after
two seconds you would have done
infinitely many steps okay you know
again why don't people try it
okay well the answer to that question is
people actually do try it they would do
what's called overclocking of their
microprocessors okay where you run your
chip at faster than the recommended
speed okay but what is the physical
problem when you do that well the
problem is if you overclock your chip
too fast it may melt okay it may
actually overheat and you know and then
no longer works so so in order to safely
run a chip faster you need a cooling
system this is why supercomputers off
this sort of you know consists of they
may just consist of some ordinary intel
chips but bei often buy cooled with
liquid nitrogen or something so that
they can be run faster ok now as you
want to run your chip faster and faster
you need more and more cooling you need
to cool it closer and closer to absolute
zero okay and now what if you wanted to
run your chip so fast that it's doing
one operation every Planck time or every
10 to the minus 43 seconds okay well no
one knows exactly what happens in that
case okay but according to the best
current physical theory it is likely
that you would need such a powerful
cooling system to cool your chip to that
you know so that it could run that fast
that you would need and you would need
so much energy to run the cooling system
that you would actually exceed the
Schwarzschild radius which actually
would cause your computer to collapse
through a black hole okay so you know I
really like that a sort of Nature's Way
of telling you that you can't do
something that you're you know they're
sort of what better way could there be
than for your computer and your whole
office to collapse to a black hole okay
okay so you know so you again once again
we see that you try to solve these
np-complete problems you have something
that looks like it's going to work but
then you know in this case sort of very
deep things about the laws of physics
seem to come into play and prevent you
from doing it okay
also maybe it won't shock you that if
closed timelike curves or time travel
existed then you could solve np-complete
problems okay it's a very simple way to
do it you know you could just read in an
integer X say from the future if X
encoded a valid solution to say your
np-complete problem then you output X
again otherwise you output the next
solution say X plus 1 mod 2 to the N
okay and now we say what are the
consistent solutions of this for this
closed timelike curve so what are the
way the things that could be fed to the
computer that will avoid a grandfather
paradox that will avoid a situation
where you would go back in time and kill
your grandfather
you know and so the universe would be
inconsistent well if the problem has any
solutions then the only consistent
evolution is for your computer to input
and output a correct solution which
nature then will have to somehow find as
if by magic just to ensure that the laws
of physics remain consistent okay so you
know an analogy would be you go back in
time and you would dictate Shakespeare's
plays to him right and so then he would
say ah thanks man that saved me a lot of
effort he'd write the plays then they
come down to you then you would have
them okay and you would go back in time
give it to him everyone's happy okay
there's no logical paradox here it's not
like the grandfather paradox the only
paradox if you like is one of
computational complexity okay that
somehow this difficult computation gets
performed Hamlet gets written somehow
without anyone ever going to the work of
writing it okay the same thing here with
how you could solve an np-complete
problem okay so yeah so I so I actually
had a research paper about this kind of
thing with John Watrous a few years ago
where we characterized exactly what you
could do with either a classical or a
quantum computer that had this
time-travel capability we showed that
it's actually larger than NP it actually
precisely coincides with a class called
P space okay this is not one of the
papers I'll be submitting to move to my
tenure committee but okay so but you
know having seen all this you might be
Wed to guess what you might call an O
SuperSearch postulate that would suggest
that this would be a strengthening of
the peanut equal to NP hypothesis that
would tell you that actually there is no
physical means whatsoever to solve
np-complete problems in polynomial time
not by a classical computer not by a
quantum computer not by a string theory
or a black hole computer not by anything
that's you know anyone will ever come up
with consistent with the laws of physics
okay so this is a very strong hypothesis
you know it's no longer purely
mathematical as P versus NP was but also
talks about the laws of physics but if
true we could use it to explain other
things
as I've been pointing out in this talk
like why adiabatic systems have small
spectral gaps why the Schrodinger
equation is linear why we don't find
closed timelike curves
you know we're hopefully more to be
discovered okay but there's a question
here which is what exactly does it mean
to solve an np-complete problem okay so
so to give you an example to illustrate
the difficulty it's been known for many
decades that if you have n identical
photons and you send them through a very
simple set up a network of mirrors
basically you beam splitters then the
amplitude for the photons to reach some
given final configuration is given by a
function which is called the permanent
of an N by n matrix in this case of
complex numbers okay so basically the
this is because photons are bosons one
of the two basic particles in the
universe right and bosons have these
very weird statistical properties okay
in particular you've got a sum so
because these are an identical particles
right there are n factorial ways that
you could rearrange them among
themselves okay each of those ways
contribute some amplitude to the total
which is then a product of individual
amplitudes and so you get a function of
an N by n matrix which is called the
permanent this is actually something
that computer scientists know extremely
well for their own reasons okay in
particular
Leslie valiant who just won the Turing
award this year one of his great
discoveries was to show that computing
the permanent of a given matrix is a
sharp P complete problem okay that means
presumably even harder than np-complete
sharp P complete is basically the class
of all counting problems problems that
involve counting the number not just
deciding whether there exists a solution
to an np-complete problem but actually
counting the number of solutions which
we think is even harder ok so so then
this raises a fascinating question okay
if the permanent is sharp P complete
then how on earth is nature computing it
okay how is it that this very simple
physical experiment has amplitudes which
are permanence of these complicated
matrices how is nature able to keep
track of this
our p-complete function given everything
I've just been telling you about the
hardness of you know certainly of
np-complete problems which are which are
which are easier than these okay so so I
think that there's a resolution of the
paradox which is instructive okay and
the resolution is that amplitudes in
quantum mechanics are not directly
observable okay as I said before an
amplitude determines the probability
that you're going to see some particular
outcome okay but if an amplitude is
exponentially small then in order to get
a good estimate of the amplitude you may
need to repeat your experiment an
exponential number of times okay and
that's really what's going on here right
so I think that we should you know we
have to say that if you know there are
many systems in nature that may seem
like they somehow encode the solution to
some np-complete or even harder problem
but if you can't actually get the answer
out by some actual physical measurement
it you know that you one could make in
principle at least then it doesn't count
okay it doesn't count so you know so
it's a good lesson now recently my
student alex arkhipov and i studied this
kind of linear optical setup and we gave
evidence that that actually it does do
something which is you know even the
observable outcomes in this experiment
are already something which is hard to
simulate by any classical computation
okay in particular we show that this
sort of linear optical setup which is
much much simpler by the way than a
full-scale quantum computer and which we
hope will be easier to build than a
full-scale quantum computer can already
sample from some probability
distribution which we can give evidence
some complexity theoretic evidence is
hard to sample from by any efficient
classical computation okay so we have no
idea how to build a universal quantum
computer with these resources or how to
implement Shor's factoring algorithm or
anything like that but for this sort of
made-up problem you know if if you you
you really really want to sample random
matrices with larger than average
permanence then have I got the computer
for you okay and you know I hope
that you know that this could actually
sort of put the extended Church touring
thesis to the test no plea an easier way
than by building a full-scale quantum
computer okay but you know our we
couldn't just say look there's a sharpie
complete end of story
because we needed to show the actual
observable consequences already encode
hard computational problems okay so that
necessitated making a more subtle
argument okay and that's why we have a
paper and not just an observation okay
so conclusions I think that one could
imagine worse research agendas than the
following prove P not equal to NP or
better yet proof factoring is
classically hard can quantum computers
solve np-complete problems in polynomial
time either
you know make progress toward building
scalable quantum computers or the more
interesting the even more interesting
thing would be to find an obstacle to it
okay I tend to be a pessimist and
believe in the more boring outcome which
is that we can build quantum computers
okay so you know can all of physics be
simulated by a quantum computer
what about string theory quantum gravity
even you know quantum field theories is
quantum computing the end of the line or
is there something else even beyond that
okay right now we don't even understand
these other theories well enough to be
able to formulate that question very
well okay and then can you know if you
accept this no super what I called the
no SuperSearch principle you know that
there's no physical way to solve these
np-complete and other hard problems can
you actually derive interesting
conclusions from that about physics okay
so I mentioned a few but I think it
would be it would be fascinating to try
to take that further okay so thank you
for your attention
[Applause]